Trump is more like Joseph Kennedy than
he's like John F Kennedy I don't know if
you know the difference Tom you know
obviously John Joseph Kennedy was
absolutely the guy that you feared
Vengeance I'm coming after you I'm gonna
come versus John F Kennedy was a guy
that never wanted to be a president he
was the younger brother with the back
problems and he had he had health issues
and his older brother who was a pilot
who was supposed to be the one that was
supposed to be the president and he was
the guy that the day his older son died
Joseph Kennedy went into depression for
a few years and then all of a sudden the
younger son is like I'm on a bench I'm
going to come and then boom John F
Kennedy and then RFK and boom the
difference here is the Father Joseph
Kennedy equals Trump exactly and Trump
is the president